okay welcome to the stream everybody we
have another big day on our hands here
it is the day of the South Carolina
Democratic primary the third primary
we've had Iowa we've had New Hampshire
we've had the Nevada caucus and then
today we have South Carolina results
starting to expected roughly around 7:30
p.m. Eastern Time which is a little over
two hours from now we have a lot of
things to look at and discuss Bernie
Sanders is in a live rally right now in
in Springfield of Virginia which we have
on screen for you as we speak we are
starting to have a number of different
exit polls come in and different things
going on which we are going to look at
I'm actually hopefully you guys can help
me I'm having trouble finding the exit
polls so that we can look at them I see
CNN I was just checking out CNN ten
minutes ago they were starting to talk
about those exit polls I would love to
find them myself I was just on the CNN
website and I'm not seeing them let me
give it the old refresh and take a look
I hope to hear from you during this live
stream we also are going to look at the
polling going in yeah I'm just not
seeing the exit polls which I would
really love to see right now I think
live updates will just take me to live
CNN which we do not necessarily want
Guardian exit polls oh let's see
Guardian South Carolina exit polls let's
see if we can find that because I would
love to check that out South Carolina
Democrats let's see here
Biden confident of beating Bernie 54
delegates in play voting is underway
recent polling do we have exit polls
yeah if somebody can send them to me
either via super chat or in some other
way
maybe if I look at the US News main page
on the Guardian and see what we can find
boy all sorts of stuff popping at the
bug Guardian website is almost
completely unusable incredibly oh we've
got opinion stuff
yeah I would love to find those so if
somebody can let me know exactly how to
fund them that would be really great the
expectation based on the polling which I
want to look at right now with you Joe
Biden with a very big recent spike in
South Carolina almost everything has
gone wrong for Joe Biden recently but
actually spiking in South Carolina along
with Bernie Sanders to the detriment of
Tom Styer the gray line here was steyr
who had paid his way all the way up into
second place and then it has just been
downhill we've seen Biden pick up hugely
Sanders pick up Budaj pick up and
Klobuchar a little bit Elizabeth Warren
down and ultimately we may only have two
candidates pulling delegates out of
South Carolina this is real this is
do-or-die in different ways for Joe
Biden and for Tom Styer for Tom Styer he
put all of his eggs into the South
Carolina basket and he was at one point
polling 18% as you can see here almost
19% and if Tom Styer were to get some
delegates today he would be able to at
least stay is justify staying in until
and through Super Tuesday and then he
would probably have to get out at that
point if steyr doesn't get any delegates
today my guess is he's out tonight and
that's it and I wouldn't be shocked he
seems to be a big fan of Bernie Sanders
Bernie Sanders of course lesson two
steyr yeah good okay as you all know and
so I would expect steyr to endorse
Bernie and Bernie to welcome it but then
move on to something else
if if Joe Biden were to not win tonight
I think Joe Biden must win tonight if
Joe Biden doesn't win tonight he has won
zero of the first four states he ends up
in an Elizabeth Warren like situation
and depending on what happens Tuesday I
don't think he gets out before Tuesday
but depending on what happens Tuesday
his path may start to to slow down my
guess is and I was on a rising with
crystal ball and cigar and jetty on
Thursday my guess is that Biden wins by
more than five or six points I think
Biden really kills it today the Sanders
campaign has already called it a quote
uphill battle in South Carolina
I expect that Biden is going to do
really really well tonight and
then it will be onward to South Carolina
to Super Tuesday rather the delegate
counts as of right now as you can see
here see if we can oh no I see okay well
really the numbers that matter are here
Bernie Sanders with 45 delegates Pete
Budaj edge with 26 Joe Biden with 15
Warren with 8 Coloma SH clover char with
7 now here's what's important to
understand South Carolina is 54
delegates as you can see here let's pull
up a calculator why don't we and then
this this I think will be instructive in
many ways for many of us let's see if I
can grab a calculator here we go ok so
here's what's important to understand as
you can see you can get more delegates
than your share of the vote because
there's this 15 percent viability
threshold so to simplify the numbers
Biden right now is polling 39.7 right so
if you take Biden's 39.7 and multiply it
by the 54 delegates that would suggest
Biden would be roughly getting 21
delegates today if he performs in
proportion with his 39.7 but you have to
understand is with that 15% viability
threshold it may only be Biden and
Sanders who get any delegates so if you
combine Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders
percentage that's 64 percent Joe might
end up actually having 62% of the viable
vote which would give him in turn thirty
three delegates roughly this is rough
math we're doing state level math for
what is actually calculated at the
district level but we have to do it that
way otherwise it gets too complicated so
Biden could actually come away with as
many as thirty three delegates today
which would put him at forty eight
extraordinarily unlikely that even if
Biden does very well that he would
overtake Bernie Sanders because Bernie
will also grab some delegates but going
into Super Tuesday
this may be a Biden Bernie leading
situation Pete budda judge may end up
with zero delegates again boo to judge
polling 11 11 you know he could pick up
a couple of Delegates depending on
whether at the district level he does
okay
but you could see Buddha judge get zero
delegates and see basically what would
be close to a close race between Biden
and Bernie but it's all momentum at this
point because of this number right here
1991 delegates needed if Bernie's up 10
delegates or 5 delegates or 15 delegates
going into Super Tuesday Super Tuesday
is really the day where we will either
see paths open to more candidates
dividing up the delegates or we will see
paths narrow and maybe we may end Super
Tuesday with two likely scenarios one
Bernie gets the most gets 50% plus one
or no one gets 50% plus one unless you
see a big big surprising performance on
Super Tuesday it's unlikely that any
other candidate will have a path to 50%
plus one although we may see a likely
scenario where nobody gets to 50% plus
one and in fact let's pull up the 538
numbers on that because these are
interesting and as you can see here as
you can't well you sort of can see what
you see here is that right now as of
right now and I believe that this is
because of the Super Tuesday numbers
which will look at momentarily right now
the most likely scenario at 52% is this
black line which means no one gets the
delegates they need Bernie
at 32% gets the delegates he needs Biden
climbing a little bit it's that purple
line but now now it is a majority
likelihood that no one gets the 1991
pledged delegates and this is this is
sort of what I've been suggesting from
the beginning people saying oh this is
David being a centrist no this is David
looking at the data okay you guys know
I'm voting for Bernie okay I'm telling
it to you as it is not as we might like
it to be and the math is increasingly
that no one gets 50% plus one in advance
of the convention it's data its data
Dave as people are saying I'm just
giving you the facts if people don't
like facts if you don't like facts there
are plenty of other streams you could be
looking at right now so in a second I
want to get to the
the Super Tuesday polling and and start
to look at that and again if folks have
any way for me to get the exit polls
I would love to pull up the exit polls
let me know and I will I want to pull
those up and take a look at them all
right let me start to thank people and
mention different things that we have
going on first and foremost I want to
say thank you to Justin Jones Justin
Jones just grabbed a membership at join
pakman.com and his new member number one
out of 50 one out of 50 as you can see
there we have a goal of 50 the coupon
code 2020 now will save you 66% off of a
membership at join pakman.com I welcome
you to go ahead and grab a membership I
want to say thank you to Shane errs on
twitch for gifting a subscription Shane
errs now is in the sixth position of all
time top sub gift errs that's a mouthful
I may indeed be hanging out with Stephen
Kenneth destiny bonel the second here in
Boston tomorrow he is in town and we've
been we've been we've been texting I may
be seeing him tomorrow I may be seeing
Hasan
Kenneth destiny [ __ ] the second
tomorrow as well and if I do I will of
course have updates for all of you let's
get to some of the super chats that are
coming in waffles Durrell's asks is 1
million subscriptions around the general
election in the ballpark for your
channel maybe we are we are trying to
get to a million youtube subscriptions
by Election Day we're at 800 and 10,000
so we have we have 109 let's see what
the math looks like we have a hundred
and ninety thousand subscribers to go
between now and about eight months so
that means we need to gain 24,000
subscribers a month in order to hit a
million by Election Day it's possible
but it's uh it's what we would call a
stretch goal that's for sure
scrawly TV says hello from North
Charleston South Carolina my girlfriend
says your headshot is very attractive
but it also looks like a memorial
picture which saddens her oh yeah I
posted too
to my Instagram a couple of days ago I
got some professional headshots taken
and I posted one that's pretty wacky and
I'm kind of kidding it's not really
going to be my new professional headshot
but check it out a lot of people are
furious comments include defying gravity
bedhead what's going on up there
the Trump era has taken its toll on
David it's a modern-day mullet your
options for job opportunities will be
extremely limited if you use that
headshot so you can check it out I have
no way of really putting it up on screen
but I'm David Pakman on Instagram and
you can check it out there a Wes says
burn baby burn Jess says thanks for all
you do david mike Lightner says this
will be Biden's first state win in three
tries at running for president that may
indeed be the case Jimmy big nut says on
trumpets dreams do you think they make
fun of people who don't use caps lock
and do you spell checker it may be that
that maybe I'm not usually on Trump
streams Andrew bayum says every
candidate is visiting Utah here next
week
could they be trying to capitalize from
the MIT Romney vote Salt Lake County is
very blue lately that's interesting yeah
I don't know what let's take a look at
the Utah polling if we can overrun Real
Clear Politics Utah Democratic primary
we have a new poll Bernie twenty eight
Bloomberg 19 Mini 19 Warren 15 Buddha
judge 18 Wow okay
Biden six Clovis are four so Bernie
Bernie looking pretty solid right now in
Utah interesting that's interesting I
will look into that more Thomas Mooney
says CNN 55% black 41 percent white 3%
Hispanic 1% other 96 97 98 99 100
okay anybody know how I can find the
exit polls any exit polls that I would
be able to find let's see us somebody
told me that the Guardian had exit polls
available let's see if we can find those
Guardian Oh Guardian is here
ah News US politics let's take a look at
that South Carolina primary results hmm
I'm not seeing the exit polls on the
Guardian campaign obviously we don't
have actual results yet but I am not
seeing that let me see if I can find the
CNN exit poll reporting politics see
what we've got
South Carolina primary who is winning
delegate leaders yeah I'm just not
finding the exit polls if anybody can
help me please do I am very much looking
forward to checking out these exit polls
we are expecting results in a couple of
hours in a couple a couple of hours away
from exit polls still at this point in
time let me welcome some new people I
want to say hello and thank you to Ryan
summers Ryan summers is new member
number two today at join pakman.com
James oh boy here we go with the
difficult last names James Mattoon --an
James Mattoon --an is new member number
three I apologize James if I've just
butchered your name I want to say thank
you to Belinda Alba Canfield who is new
member number four today at join
pakman.com we have a generous but
generous but achievable goal of 50 new
members also want to say thanks to Ed
zone for subscribing with twitch Prime
and Fenwick for subscribing with
subscribing for eight months on twitch
as well
squirrel OSIS says if somehow Bernie
wins South Carolina he'll win the
nomination I mean I only go by the
polling I find it very unlikely Bernie
will win South Carolina but stranger
things have happened and he could he
could certainly over perform Frank won
Rouge says why do a lot of Americans
think Europeans are communists because
we are free and got socialist programs
why do people believe those
I'm Dutch okay some things I don't have
answers for my friend dillinger sciatic
says will South Carolina victory be of
real significance for Biden for abide in
winning South Carolina and will winning
it for a lot would give him it would
avoid having to get the hell out very
soon and it would probably give him some
momentum into Super Tuesday if Biden
were to underperform the polls
significantly it would be very very bad
for him it would be there so it's more
avoiding disaster then so it would be of
significance in avoiding disaster
downfall parodies one says how will the
media spin vibe I'd ins victory against
Bernie well for one they want they
they'll finally have something they
don't have to spin they'll just be able
to report Biden won and potentially by a
significant number we are live on
YouTube twitch and Facebook welcome to
everybody joining us we are awaiting
results in South Carolina we are
hopefully soon going to get some exit
polls let's just dig in a tiny bit here
to the Bernie rally while I look at one
other spot potentially for the exit
polls give me a moment here a year on
weapons of destruction
maybe we should pool our resources fight
our common enemy which is climate change
[Applause]
and when we talk about issues that
cannot be swept under the rug
we have got to recognize Bernie's voice
not not sounding too good okay as a hype
train explodes on Twitch I am still
unable to find those exit polls but if
somebody tells me where to find them we
will immediately pull those up to review
if you are just joining us we do have
South Carolina polling which saw a big
spike for Joe Biden this is me just
reporting the polls just reporting the
polls I'm merely the messenger I didn't
do the polls I didn't suggest to people
how to respond to polls I'm merely
reporting the polls and Joe Biden doing
very well there we have as of now 45
delegates for Bernie Sanders 26 for
Budaj edge 15 for Biden 8 for Warren and
7 for Chlo Bashar nobody else really in
this thing Tom Styer hoping hoping for
some delegates today
let's y/o actually is so there are
actually more questions coming in and
other things so let me let me actually
answer questions and then I have some
videos that I wanted to play for you
guys as well I've got a lot of different
stuff to get through today as we await
results downfall parodies oh no so we
got that one already
ZM thanks for all you do thank you
Benjamin Potter says do you think Mike
Bloomberg is running as a financial
calculation like if a progressive wins
and implements a wealth tax he stands to
lose much more than what he has invested
in the campaign you know here's the
thing I don't think we're gonna get a
wealth tax no matter who's president in
the next four years that's my view now
we can argue about a wealth tax versus
upping the top marginal tax rate versus
upping the capital gains rate or
whatever I don't believe we will get a
wealth tax
I don't believe obviously we're
Republicans aren't going to go for it
many if not most Democratic senators are
not going to go for it I don't think we
get a wealth tax so I think that this is
more complicated than Bloomberg is
running to avoid a wealth tax because I
don't I think he knows even if Elizabeth
wood
you're not gonna pass the 2% wealth tax
with what is probably going to be a
Republican Senate and maybe would just
barely become a Democratic Senate in
2022 I just don't think it's gonna
happen and again I tell you things as I
believe they are not as I would
necessarily like them to be
cheeseburgers 7:47 says thanks for your
reporting Eric o says they're blaming
Dow Dow Jones Plus Corona on supreme
leader the fightin Hobbit says Biden
couldn't book lassie in a pet shop
window Isaac Mendez has grabbed a
YouTube membership at the soy boy level
and Jared Bartel says what do you think
the most likely outcome would be in the
general Biden was able to steal if Biden
was able to steal the nomination from
Bernie so I have two thoughts on this
the polling says every Democratic
challenger beats Trump my intuition says
it's going to be very difficult for any
of the Democratic challengers to defeat
Trump when you look a little more
closely at the states likely to be the
key States so you have my optimistic
self and my more realist self and I
believe that it is no matter what the
polls say it is going to be a very
difficult a 2020 general election no
matter who the nominee is let's welcome
a couple of other new members we have a
goal of 50 website members I want to
welcome Gabriel Hassan or Hassan I
believe when it's two S's it's
pronounced Hassan Allen ciccone isn't
that Madonna's last name I believe that
Madonna's last name is Ciccone or is it
Ciccone now I'm not sure Allen thank you
you were new member number six today I
also want to say thanks to Frank Witter
who is new member number seven today at
joined pakman.com Frank doing the
Frank's clever Frank took advantage of
that coupon code 2020 now which saves
you 66 percent let me say thank you to
some folks over on twitch Nathan Rogers
has grabbed the twitch Prime
subscription Larry Hova has subscribed
with prime and jacked cowboy jack
cowboy has subscribed at Tier one as
well
let's see other questions team machine
says your reading of the polls is very
by obviously very biased and sarcasm yes
when I read the polls I'm clearly in
injecting my opinion seth Simonelli says
were you at the rally in Boston today it
was packed no I tend to avoid large
crowds and it was just a zoo I had a
bunch of different stuff to do today I
was around town I did not go wow things
getting crazy at this Bernie rally very
clearly I I did not go I just avoid
stuff like that it's not it's not my cup
of tea I'm not a agoraphobic or anything
like that but I just uh
it's I didn't want to stand from 10:00
to noon at the common waiting for Bernie
it was it was a mess but I heard it was
great Edward Forrester says stop saying
a Bloomberg yeah I should just call a
mini right Jared Bartel has grabbed a
youtube subscription soldier of science
says if the DNC steals the candidacy
from Bernie again I swear I'll vote for
Trump and independent well then you'll
help Trump win which maybe would be what
you want to do in that scenario
dillinger see attic says CNN has
articles South Carolina Democratic voter
demographics set state's primary apart
from previous three contests exit polls
show as of 5:14 let's see if we can find
that let's see here
here it is 16 minutes ago let's see if
we can find some of these actual exit
polls okay oh boy everything now
freezing up there we go okay but let's
see here four and ten South Carolina
electorate so far is more religiously
active than Democratic primary voters in
New Hampshire for intense a they attend
religious services at least once a week
that was only 13% in New Hampshire
that's connected to the racial diversity
of the electorate but not entirely
driven by it a majority of black
Democratic primary voters in South
Carolina say they attend services
weekly compared with three in ten white
voters South Carolina's electorate
includes more voters who describe
themselves as moderate or conservative
than any of the other three states to
vote thus far half call themselves
moderate or conservative here compared
with a third in Iowa and Nevada and
roughly four in ten in New Hampshire one
in five said they made up their minds
earlier in February and about twice as
many said they decided whom to support
before February interesting South
Carolina Democratic representative james
Clyburn slate endorsement of Joe Biden
was a critical factor for a quarter see
this is that's actually very interesting
my position for years has been I don't
believe endorsements really matter very
much except when they do in very
specific and narrow situations I said
when we covered it on Tuesday or
Wednesday that cleburn's endorsement of
Biden in South Carolina did matter and
it appears that 25% of the primary
voters are saying it did matter and that
is important one in five voters were
participating in their first primary
that's slightly higher than the cher who
said so in New Hampshire
I assume first-time primary voters are
more likely to vote for someone other
than Biden that's my instinct but we
will ultimate to ultimately see if that
is true
35 precincts full sample of a margin of
four percentage points very interesting
okay so I if you guys don't disagree my
sense is that the the exit polls so far
also favor Joe Biden which is what we've
been thinking for a little while there's
every news website now just have a toxic
level of popups is that is that what it
is it's quite wild so we still have a
Bernie rally going on if anybody has
other coverage that they think I should
pick up the video from this Bernie rally
has been just absolutely horrible I'm
glad to switch to some something else as
we await results here let's see other
super chats coming in me person says
disregard the other guy definitely call
him blight Bloomberg Nicko's rap says
wyr would you rather have Alex Jones
or Jesse Lee Peterson is president Jesse
Lee Peterson or Alex Jones you know
maybe Jesse Lee because Jesse Lee is
less overtly conspiratorial than Alex
Jones maybe I'm trying to think that
through Jeff probably Jesse Lee yeah I
think Jesse Lee Peterson over Alex mr.
Biskit says will you join the hundreds
of thousands protesting in Milwaukee if
the DNC attempts to steal the election
from Bernie at the contested convention
you know it's it's not that easy to
last-minute go to Milwaukee during a
convention I am I'm in talks now with a
couple of our partners to be there for
the entire convention doing stuff be at
a couple conferences and different
things I may be there I may not but it's
it's unlikely that they'll at the last
minute I would go I the plans will
likely be made of very very much ahead
of time wasting time says it'd be
hilarious if you did joint primary
election commentary with Jesse Lee
Peterson that would be funny Jack Finley
Zach Finley says hey David wanted to say
hi thanks for your service here tonight
also thanks for the half off membership
deal I took advantage of best wishes
thank you and ebony Washington says who
do you think the super-delegates will
give the election to if we end up at a
brokered convention my guess is
whichever centrist candidate has the
most delegates at that time that that's
my that's my sense let me say thank you
and welcome to some other new members
who are really doing an amazing amazing
things
Gabriel Joseph is new member number
eight tonight at join pakman.com or this
afternoon depending on where you're
watching from tour mud casbah is new
member number nine tonight and joshua
storm is new member number ten tonight
join these great people by grabbing a
membership at join pakman.com coupon
code available but not mandatory as you
can see up there 2020 now saves you
two-thirds let's see what we have
happening over on twitch not that much
not that much thanks to brent stone i
believe is the username for the bits
with the message what was the message
with the bits i'm having trouble finding
it here
Oh voted for Bernie in South Carolina
this morning no issues hoping for better
than expected results all right very
good let's see what else we might have
if we put South Carolina's primary and
then we filter by live let's see what
else so my stream comes up first that's
interesting none of these other streams
are striking me as particularly exciting
we have MSNBC stuff let's see if there's
anything here that is of interest to us
oh they actually are running some of the
some of the exit polls
let's see South Carolina Democratic
primary voters have you ever voted in a
primary before 81% yes 18% no okay this
actually may be interesting let's see
what we can glean from this stuff as we
see a commercial for freshly aged 17 to
29 10 % 1843 and 29 that seems
relatively standard based on the
prevailing age demographics in South
Carolina to me 55 percent women 45% men
okay let's see what's next
up in the exit polls feelings about
Trump administration oh and it just
disappeared oh is joy read everybody's
favorite broadcaster everybody's
favorite centrist broadcaster an hour in
25 minutes of course until the polls
close as you probably know by now okay
I'm actually interested in seeing what
the what what the exit poll data
suggests here over on YouTube let's see
here want to make sure I don't miss
anybody here waffles derp awful says
amazin autocorrection is beta Tyler and
the residents say mr. mayor Mini Mike
Bloomberg er Dominic quintanilla says
glad your channel is doing good on
streams David thank you I appreciate
that
Jake Easter do you have a good source
for news in Spanish you would recommend
you know one there's a guy who has a
show I believe it's out in Cali
his name is Fernando espuelas he is sort
of Argentinean Hawaiian I believe he was
born in one and raised in the other or
something he does a show that's partly
in English partly in Spanish he's really
good I like him a lot
I think it's on Univision radio Seth
Barham says hi David thanks for your
coverage have you or do you plan to make
any preparations for the impending
coronavirus epidemic you know let me
actually I want to show you guys
something I've been thinking let me pop
up another window here I think you might
find this interesting I've been looking
at a couple different things and I've
been doing this to try to be prepared so
first thing I did is I looked at n95
masks and I saw that they were being
gouged like look at these some of these
prices actually a hundred for a hundred
and sixty bucks doesn't seem crazy but
my idea was I might grab a full face
respirator mask and use this for doing
the show the only concern about it is I
don't know that the mic will easily pick
pick up my I think it'll distort the
audio but I was considering wearing a
full-face respirator safety mask
including possibly goggles and maybe
even one with the double filters let me
see if I can find a better example of
what I've been looking at something more
like where is the double anyway once
that one that's sort of like this but
with the double filters just to make a
point during the show that was one idea
then I also thought about getting it's
like let me see if I can find it there's
a particular type of face mask it's like
a face shield face shield yeah I was
thinking of getting something like this
just stocking up in Altered during
during coronavirus stories wearing these
things so wear a face shield I think
that that would allow me better better
sort of audio and then I was also
thinking let me see if I can find it
it's like a beekeeper mask now this
isn't exactly what I was looking for
maybe more of a hazmat head covering
I can't find it now but I was also gonna
grab a hazmat hat it's basically like
just the top piece of a beekeepers
outfit and I was gonna rotate those
things during coronavirus segments and
that you know part of it is it would be
sort of visually compelling and it might
get some attention but I I actually
think that we are in such trouble with
the current administration's handling of
coronavirus and that's actually maybe
maybe this is an opportunity to deal
with some of that stuff I have some
videos that I posted listened to Trump
sounds all barely conscious
in this latest coronavirus press
conference where he started talking
about Isis it's been a long journey in
Afghanistan in particular it's been a
very long journey it's been a it's been
a hard journey for everybody we're very
largely a law-enforcement group and
that's not what our soldiers are all
about their fighters are the greatest
fighters in the world as you know we've
destroyed in Syria and Iraq 100% of the
Isis Caliphate 100% we have thousands of
prisoners yeah so this entire thing was
about coronavirus incredibly and we have
other videos that are west currently
that have coronavirus unfortunately one
person passed away overnight which was a
wonderful woman a medically high-risk
patient in her late 50s four others are
very ill thankfully 15 are either
recovered fully or they're well on their
way to recovery yeah there's another one
healthy people if you're healthy you
will probably go through a process and
you'll be fine yeah I'm convinced
everything's going to be fine also
really weirdly last night from talking
about how he has ordered elements of
medical now you might be wondering what
does he mean by elements is he talking
about elements as in like oxygen boron
silica what it what does he mean by
elements of medical I have no idea a lot
of spirit
and as you know with the flu
on average we lose from 26,000 to 78,000
people here even more than that and some
some cases some years we haven't lost
anybody yet and hopefully we can keep
that in there and we there have been no
deaths in the United States at all a lot
of that's attributable to the fact that
we closed the border very early that
otherwise it could be a different story
so yeah yesterday I posted video of
flight records of planes flying in from
Shanghai to LA so that's not true
well we'll just keep doing a good job
we're ordering a lot of supplies we're
ordering a lot of a lot of elements and
frankly we wouldn't be ordering unless
it was something like this but we're
ordering a lot of different elements of
medico we are elements of medical
they've ordered elements of medical we
we are seriously screwed I mean it is
just it's shocking how screwed we are
let I'm not loving this stream let me
see if I can find another another better
stream that might have some exit polls
for us I love that if you search for
live streams for the South Carolina
primary this live stream is the first
one that comes up that's great but does
ABC have anything for us let's see if
they have anything coming in so far and
I by the way if you are just joining me
if you're just joining us on Twitch
please make sure you're following my
twitch channel we are trying to get to
30,000 twitch followers if you were
watching on YouTube please hit the like
button and hit the subscribe button this
stuff is free guys it really it costs
nothing it's my request to you we've
been doing all these streams I'm not
asking for much hit that like button and
hit that subscribe button and we are we
are trying to get to a million YouTube
subscribers by Election Day and I don't
think that it is a crazy goal of course
with with your help let's see so at 6
p.m. okay so we're 15 minutes away from
the live South Carolina coverage so
we'll keep it here momentarily and see
see what comes up alright I don't want
to fall behind on thanking people who
are supporting the stream so let me do
that right now
let's see here Susan Pell Susan thank
you you are new
number eleven today at join pakman.com
diana Felder diana thank you you were
new member number twelve today at join
pakman.com Denise long you were new
member number thirteen today very much
appreciate your support we do have a an
ambitious but achievable goal of 50 new
website members today and I love all the
folks that have been that have been
supporting we have our delegate count if
you're just joining us Bernie Sanders
currently leading the delegate count and
Pete Budaj and second-place Joe Biden in
third by every expectation based on the
polling in South Carolina we are
expecting that Joe Biden will be close
to Bernie in delegates after everything
is all said and done today but would
you've got to count the votes this is
why we do the elections we are starting
to get some exit polling numbers let's
see if we have anything new here I would
love to just see the exit polling absent
sort of the narrative that we are
getting in this article but I'm not
seeing any place to do that
they are sort of telling a story about
the exit polling but I am not actually
seeing just the facts as as the kids
these days like to say okay let's get to
some other super chats mister app be oh
sorry I scrolled by mr. app B says early
voted for Bernie in North Carolina
crossing my fingers
Dillinger's see attic says video quality
of Bernie's rally looks like 1972 yeah
that's why we got away from it the real
life Channel are you worried the corona
virus will cause problems for the
primaries will the DNC cancel or suspend
getting sick while campaigning what's
your take I don't think so I don't I
don't think so but listen if if it
really gets as bad as some believe it's
going to get anything could happen
Mike Lightner says I'm feeling the Bern
but the campaign really needs to get a
better streaming set up this isn't the
first time where they've had clogged
with pipes
yeah yesterday's rally in Springfield
Massachusetts was fine today's not so
good
Katie Hayes has just finished a tower
volunteer shift to Kansas
canvas door knock for Bernie in
Charlotte most people who talk seem
concerned about other people not
rallying behind him or other Democrats
obstructing his policies interesting JDS
third with a super chat Jordan Hollister
says could destiny beat Jesse Lee
Peterson in a boxing match yeah I think
so
destiny is not a big guy but neither is
Jesse Lee all I'm gonna see destiny
tomorrow for lunch it looks like I will
I'll ask him
Dominique quintanilla says guests on
destiny store stream said you had some
bad hot takes oh I cares I don't even I
don't even know who that guest was Jacob
ball Dave you can get gas masks with
attachments for voice they're used for
radio communications while wearing the
mask that can't possibly be true can it
let's take a look here uh gas mask audio
let's see yeah I'm sure that I'm getting
trolled now but I'm not finding anything
like that if that really exists I would
be very very curious to see it let me
know if that's actually for real
Jane womanpower sick how phony Trump is
in his quiet voice ah yeah James
Montalbano this administration is going
to disappear one day it's like a miracle
it will disappear but it could get worse
before it gets better yeah it could be
January of 2021 or it could be January
of 2025 Oh someone's saying search for a
Darth Vader Vader
audio mask hmm these mostly seem like
children's toys Star Wars electronic
helmet you know I don't know that that's
I don't know that I'm willing to go
quite so far I don't know that I need
that let me say thanks to some people
over on Twitch let's see I don't want to
miss anybody alh 9700 says thanks David
for the extensive coverage of the
caucuses and the independent news source
kudos from Bordeaux welcome multibeast
says member of the day February 6th 27
tene a day that will live in infamy
glaive magic sent some bits haiku three
three three subscribed with prime very
much appreciate that thank you other
questions continuing to come in max says
am i right to feel relatively powerless
against the DNC Bloomberg's plutocracy
and uninformed voters it feels like such
an uphill battle it is an uphill battle
but it is not an impossible battle and
that I think is the important thing
listen if we don't get out and do our
thing
then it definitely is impossible that's
why it's so important to do so rational
Enquirer has grabbed a YouTube
membership mass Mac PI's oops
scrolled past Magpies nest productions
think anyone will drop out after Super
Tuesday yeah I expect steyr will be out
after Super Tuesday
tulsi still has no path to even a single
delegate and she should get out now if
not after Super Tuesday so yeah I expect
the race to narrow after Super Tuesday
thanks to Matthew Kelly for signing up
with a youtube membership Pierre
Boudreau says how would a Bernie
presidency influence Canada I have no
idea
that's uh that's more of a question for
Canadians
mr. app B says speaking of destiny what
in the hell happened to him he went from
being a good progressive to all of a
sudden becoming more centrist than Joe
Biden I don't know I don't really watch
any political shows Mike Lewis has
grabbed the YouTube membership RG
Christie says I love Joe but I think
that he would be best at Secretary of
State he knows and is liked by the
international community he could mend
the fences Biden is Secretary of State
he would certainly be qualified he
certainly wouldn't satisfy progressives
that's for sure Mike Lewis has upgraded
his membership from SOI boy to beta
Pierre Boudreau says could you say a few
sentences in French yeah it's a little
too early in the night for that Pierre
weed that we I think we need to put a
hold on maybe we'll deal with that a
little bit later if you're just joining
us we have been reviewing delegate
numbers out of South in advance of South
Carolina results we have been looking at
poll
going into South Carolina where Joe
Biden is looking strong as you see this
big spike here adding almost 50% to his
support incredibly we have reviewed some
very bizarre videos of Donald Trump who
has added elements of medical over the
last 24 hours and we've also started to
get some exit polling data for inten in
South Carolina say they're seeking a
candidate who can bring needed change a
quarter say they want a candidate who
cares about people like them and who can
unite the country the electorate in
South Carolina more religious than any
other electorate that we've seen so far
and we've been tracking all of that
information let's see what other South
Carolina live streams have cropped up in
the last 10 or 15 minutes there's hours
of course the ABC News 1 will just open
that in another tab for now not
recognizing any of these others we have
an a/c pack stream that's going on and
that is roughly it for now so we'll keep
an eye on that and ABC's coverage
expected to start in less than 10
minutes which is very exciting we are
getting closer to results that's the
important bit of news let me say thanks
to a few other new members because there
are some really great people signing up
let me say thank you and welcome to
Joseph Keefer who is new member number
14 tonight what not number 4 number 14 I
want to say thank you and welcome to
Michael Plotkin who is new member number
15 at join pakman.com autumn luciano is
new member number 16 tonight and Sasha
Porte is new member number 17 tonight if
you're just joining us a really great
way to support the stream all of these
are optional but a really great way to
support the stream is to grab a
membership at join pakman.com and we
have a coupon code 20/20 now which will
save you sixty-six percent which is
crazy
but if you just want to do something
free make sure if you're watching on
youtube you hit like and subscribe like
and subscribe like and subscribe it's
free
and if you're watching on twitch make
sure you're following my twitch channel
as we are closing in on results in South
Carolina Ric Martin says how did the VP
options compare for the top runners I
have committed myself not to get into VP
stuff until later I just think it's a
it's a distraction right now Mike Lewis
says the DNC prefers Trump over Bernie
you know sometimes I believe the same
thing sometimes I believe the same thing
Lumina M says love your work David thank
you our rich ropa thak says do a live
chat with rave D classical liberal from
LA there's an idea
blooped he says could bernie function
with a divided Congress he would likely
have no choice if you look at the
numbers Tristen Clements says people are
pointing out that Bernie exaggerated
most statistics during the South
Carolina debate what are your thoughts
there were some inaccuracies
for example Bernie said that women make
80 cents to on the dollar compared to
men my analysis is that it's really more
like 91 cents on the dollar
I would rather I would rather the right
numbers for sure at every opportunity
let's see hacked up for hacked up for BB
Q says Destiny's love of capitalism
outweighs his love of progressive
policies keep up the great work David
early voter from Oklahoma and gormer
Roth says am I crazy hoping for a Bernie
win today well no at every Bernie
supporter I guess is hoping for a Bernie
win the math of it does not seem to
favor Bernie but he is likely to pick up
some more delegates today let me say
thank you to berserk Lama who has
subscribed with twitch prime Andrew love
haves who has subscribed with twitch
prime Joseph said Agati says can I get a
hot take on the Afghanistan withdrawal I
want to get out of Afghanistan as soon
as possible and I want to do it in the
right way without causing an
issues that will pull us back in at any
future point but I did not really follow
the announcement today and I'm not sure
exactly what what Trump has cooked up
right now let me say thank you - oh no -
no one I thought I had a couple other
new members to thank but I actually did
not okay if anybody has updated exit
poll I would love to know exactly where
to find them we have sort of a narrative
of exit polls here let's see what's
happening over on the Vox results page
let's see so obviously we have no
results yet what else do we have
polls close at seven results can't be
expected until later you know I'm not
sure about that they say given the
closeness of the race results aren't
expected until later in the evening I
think we may get results tonight far
earlier or at least a call far earlier
than some people imagined Biden expected
to win but not poised for the landslide
once expected live results see what we
have under live results oh that's the
page we're on ok all right so nothing
new there and ok so I guess we don't
really have much much new going on right
now which is fine
we are soon expecting coverage to start
here on ABC and we're a little early to
the stream tonight and I think let's see
if any other streams have since started
see who else has results just that ABC
one yeah really nothing else going right
now there is still the CPAC still going
on okay so that's finally to the game
which is completely fine mark mr. app B
asks Superman versus Goku who wins I
don't know what Goku's powers are so
it'd be impossible for me to say David
Mitnick says you claim to oppose
super-delegates but you were willing to
take Super chat money why the hypocrisy
you know that's true both have the term
super in them
man I must be some kind of chill let me
say thank you
Alexandru warka for grabbing a boy level
membership over on youtube i also want
to say thanks to Brent Corrigan for the
twitch Prime subscription and to
Comstock rocker for the twitch Prime
subscription thank you very much I
really appreciate that support I would
love to see in the chat now on both
YouTube and twitch
we are also live on Facebook but I can't
see the chat there because the interface
is just not particularly friendly to us
who do you believe will win tonight not
who do you support
right not who do you support who do you
believe will win tonight in South
Carolina do you agree with the polls or
or not a lot of people say Trump will
win tonight it seems Biden okay it seems
everybody is essentially understanding
the polling numbers some people
wondering whether Tulsi will win tonight
or whether there will be a clove Bashar
clobbering the clover train people
jumping on that Martin O'Malley I think
John Edwards has a real shot I mean
South Carolina's his home state Bernie
so a lot of people say Bernie's going to
win I just don't see the math of it
unless the polls are just so so so wrong
a lot of clova trainers interesting John
Delaney maybe yang yeah yang might win
tonight who knows oh wait no how John
Edwards is from North Carolina that's
right I apologized it's been so long
since he's been around that I forgot
Bloomberg I don't even think Bloomberg
is running or many as some people want
him referred to okay looks like some
coverage is starting here let's see what
we've got this is an ABC News election
update update
[Music]
welcome to ABC News live thanks for
streaming with us we'll be bringing you
updates on the votes in the South
Carolina primary all night we are just
about an hour away from the polls
closing right for Vice President Joe
Biden has been the front-runner in this
state serene Charlotte so we'll keep an
eye they may actually have some exit
polls for us I know a lot of people are
mad they say that when I talk about the
math that that's establishment biased
math I know you're probably joking but
if you're not seek help seek help and
very very quickly let me say thank you
to Tara
faerie Tara faerie is new member number
18 tonight at join pakman.com and Scott
who is Inga
Scott was Inga is new member number 19
tonight thank you Scott appreciate your
support
join these great people at join
pakman.com and remember that it costs
nothing to follow my channel on Twitch
or to subscribe and like subscribe and
like on YouTube all of that stuff is
free yeah
people are saying I've sold out too big
math I have this this show has been a
shill for just looking at data for a
very long time and if there is any power
that we are subservient to it is the
process of mathematics statistics and
science that you got me guys you got me
other super chats that are coming in
let's see here Jordan Hollister asks did
you enjoy your visit to my country
England I did it I went to England in
December it was not my first visit but I
was in London and Oxford and loved it
I'm not that big on British food or
although I did do with like a Sunday
roast thing at a local pub and it was
cool now that was really good and then
the Indian food is of course big Lee
tremendous in London and what else was
good in London there was some good uh
there was a great little Japanese cafe
where I got some great breakfast near
where I stayed and no yes I enjoyed it I
enjoyed it thoroughly
Jason bovver says if bernie comes up
short
then Warren's fifty delegates might push
them over should we rebuild the bridge
by
president SOS that bridge may already
have been rebuilt privately and we just
don't know it will be it will be a sight
to behold
I hate juice sends a super chat DMACC
has grabbed a youtube sub comrade
Matthias says Jeb is going to win
tonight listen it is as likely that Jeb
wins tonight as it is that Tulsi wins
tonight in the Democratic primary let me
go on record and say that Donna P has
grabbed the YouTube subscription mister
app B says is Kyle kolinsky really
bought by big seltzer not that I'm aware
of I didn't think he had a big Seltzer
sponsor Nick asks hi David have you ever
been to the Netherlands I've been - I've
been to Amsterdam and I've been to
Maastricht those are the two places that
I've visited in the Netherlands and
absolutely loved both of them a rich row
path Acts says where do you get good
Indian food in Boston
there's a place in you know what I'm not
even really sure I'm not sure where I
get good Indian food in Boston there's a
couple good places in Roslindale or at
least one what's the place in Roslindale
called it might be what is that Indian
place in Raleigh I don't know but
there's a there's a good Indian food
place in Roslindale that I like I'm less
familiar with the Indian food
restaurants here here in the city of
Boston if you are just joining us we are
57 minutes away from polls closing in
South Carolina we are standing by for
what will likely be based on the polling
not based on my opinion a fight mostly
between Bernard Sanders and Joseph R
Biden Jr Biden polling 30 almost 40
percent averaged going in including as
high as 44 in South Carolina Bernie
Sanders polling an average of twenty
four point three nobody else even
polling in the viability threshold so it
may just be Biden and Sanders who pulled
delegates today if there are some
specific areas where steyr or Budaj edge
can get to 15% at a district level then
they may grab some delegates that is
certainly possible but that is
that that's the way it's looking right
now we've been keeping an eye on
different live streams that are covering
the South Carolina primary today we have
oh we we have the CBS stream now let's
see what they've got going on hi Lane
well in previous early States we've been
talking a lot about how voters were
undecided either going into the caucuses
or going into the polling booths I would
say it's a different feeling here in
South Carolina because Joe Biden enjoys
such a big everybody doing basically the
same stuff there's a PBS live stream as
well but they are not they don't seem to
be covering the election so we will sort
of check out what's happening on CBS
we'll keep an eye on what's happening on
ABC as well and keep an eye on the
results some early early exit polls so
far suggesting that the electorate in
South Carolina is more racially diverse
than those that we've seen and more
religious than those that we've seen so
far let's see other Super chats coming
in Winston maquettes says if Bernie does
win South Carolina Biden should drop out
a lot of people feel that way
Daniel Abram has signed up on YouTube
liquids back says Biden will win but it
will be a Pyrrhic victory a victory a
Pyrrhic victory for people not familiar
with that term a Pyrrhic victory is a
victory during which so much damage is
incurred by the eventual victor that it
is in the long term or in broad strokes
not really a victory hopefully hopefully
people agree with my definition of
Pyrrhic victory reckless eating has
grabbed a twitch Prime subscription and
Benz 128 has done the same I also want
to say thank you to Kasper seaman who
has grabbed the membership I actually
it's weird I've met a bunch of people
named Kasper recently and I didn't know
what the I don't know what the
background what's the origin of the name
Kasper it sounds just British right or I
guess I don't know
it's interesting that I like it Walker
Anderson I know her fans bug you
understandably but why do you insist on
calling Tulsi Tulsi I don't know what
you mean at the end of the day she
served our country and you didn't I have
no clue what that I mean so you can't
refer to people who have been in the
military if you haven't that's weird I
don't really get them michael barratt
says what was the cause of Biden's huge
jump in part the endure endorsement from
congressman Clyburn RG Christie what do
you think it will take to unite the
party and start concentrating on
defeating Trump and the Republicans this
is the position of the Lincoln project
probably getting past the primary to be
perfectly honest I'm not seeing that
unity until we get past or at least
closer to what it what feels like an
inevitable result in the primary will
ready says what are your thoughts on
chances for a Tulsi VP pick from Bernie
I would say almost zero ESOP twin I
think vermin's supreme is winning i met
vermin he's been on the show but I also
met vermin in New Hampshire on primary
day last election cycle
Emily kill coin says what's up with
Biden's sudden ascension again that
endorsement from Biden focused on South
Carolina knew that he had to do well and
put a lot of resources there went there
I believe he went there wild New
Hampshire was voting or while nevado I
don't remember now but he went there
very very early and the endorsement from
Clyburn certainly did not hurt Daniel
Huberman says do you think debate
performances are overhyped well the
further in you get the less a debate
performance is going to move the needle
one way or the other unless someone does
so poorly that you know it's it implodes
their campaign mr. app B asks why has
hardly anyone brought up Trump's praised
of Kim jong-un
when anyone on the right brings up the
Castro comments I feel like trumps are
worse you will people on the left are
not likely to do that and then people on
the right aren't going to do that
because
it's not in their interest so I think
that I'm not sure who would bring it up
typically Trent Tanner says will this
win propel Biden to secure the Senate
seat he's running for or will voters go
with the other Biden yeah people didn't
see the other day Biden said I am
running for the US Senate and it was a
really weird moment very very strange
moment let's see here
super chats continuing to come in Paul
sir nosov has sent the superjet joseph
Dizzy's says casper is an old persian
name for treasurer oh that's interesting
did not know that the the Jake Tucker
says bababooey bababooey bababooey you
got me wow squirrely OSes Caspar German
and Slovak from the personal name Caspar
or Kaspar originally from Persian kebaya
Kazan Adar or gangs VAR meaning treasure
bearer ascribed to one of the three
Maguy or Magi Wow a big history there
Zachary Monroe hey David Zach from
Flagstaff I'm here with you every time
you stream I enjoy your commentary and
coverage you helped me understand this
confusing political world
hashtag support for the David Pakman
show Thank You Zachary I know you've
been here at a lot of these Comrade
Matthias have you heard Trump told
supporters to vote Bernie in South
Carolina do you think it'll have an
effect no I don't parrot earrin says
Kasper were one of the men visiting
Jesus according to the serial book Bible
all right a lot of different views about
the name Kasper Walker Anderson says
play coy all you want but you were
pronouncing tool C's name in an attempt
to call her a tool it's tall C tall so
tall C that is interesting that's
different
rec Sol says do you ever get visibly
angry or punched the air I don't I don't
punch the air JD s third Wolf Blitzer
and Chris Matthews have their heads and
hearts explode on air if Bernie wins
tonight breaking the news oh that's the
other clip I
to show you guys while we wait Chris
Matthews last night mixed up his black
people check this out
this is video of this is Lindsey Graham
and this is Tim Tim Scott
I almost said Tim Apple Tim Scott who
are the two Republican senators from
South Carolina now there's a guy named
Jamie Harrison who also happens to be a
black man running against Lindsey Graham
what I'm in a play for you here is Chris
Matthews they he knows he's about to
interview Jamie Harrison he seems to
think that the video is of Jamie
Harrison next to Lindsey Graham and it
gets super awkward check this out Jamie
I see you standing next to the guy
you're gonna beat right there maybe
maybe maybe Lindsey Graham Tim Scott
Jamie who's that Scott big mistake
mistaken identity sir sorry tell me how
you're gonna be done yeah there you go
so not it was pretty cringe it was
pretty cringe NBC politics website has
some interesting exit polls let's see if
we can find that NBC politics let's find
it and see what exit polls we've got oh
my god this is just toxically difficult
to see um where are these exit polls ah
here we go
very interesting let's see more than a
half dozen okay early state Democratic
primary and caucus voters ideology so
the South Carolina electorate is the
least liberal and most conservative not
hugely surprising let's see what else
we've got
oh my god that's the only thing they
have so all right let's let's read
through more than 6 and 10 voters in
Iowa New Hampshire no matter more than 6
in 10 voters would rather see a nominee
who can beat Trump but South Carolina
Democrats are not as focused on victory
slightly more than half say they
prioritize beating Trump strong support
for Medicare for all support for the
plan implementer of state now it's high
okay alright so they have a few
interesting things I would
let's see is this so we don't have so I
wish we could just get just the data so
that we could interpret the data if you
guys know what I mean I would really
love that let's see what other info kay
so we have other exit polls at the
bottom of the screen here let me see if
I can put those on screen a little more
clearly for you guys there we go
okay 53% prefer someone who can beat
Trump over someone who agrees with you
on issues that's interesting similar to
the NBC data waiting for the next one
replace all private health insurance
with a government plan 50% of poor
opposed I'm sorry 50% support forty-four
percent opposed that's actually pretty
pretty close that's not that
overwhelming interestingly enough other
exit poll data that maybe all they're
gonna show us for right now okay welcome
if you are just joining us we are live
on YouTube twitch and Facebook if you
are joining on twitch please hit that
follow button it costs nothing and we
really appreciate all of the folks
following us if you're watching on
YouTube please hit that like button
we have 5,000 live viewers and only
1,500 people who like to the stream hit
that like button and please hit that
subscribe button as well it is free it
is completely free to hit the subscribe
button and we actually may be pretty
close yeah we're very close to getting
to eight hundred and eleven thousand
subscribers only a couple hundred away
so make sure you hit that subscribe
button as well on YouTube okay let's
answer some more Super chats oh no but
first I have to thank a couple of other
people I want to say thank you to vada
dal set who is new member number 21 at
join pakman.com I want to point out to
you that there are we have a goal of 50
new members and we are currently at 21
these are website members at join
pakman.com why website members because
our payment system takes the tiniest
sliver compared
to twitch YouTube patreon all this other
stuff you can save 66 percent with the
coupon code 2020 now I think we only
need like what do we have 1100 people
1200 people watching on twitch 5000 on
YouTube
another hundred on Facebook if only like
0.3% of the people watching grab a
membership right now at join pakman.com
we will instantly hit that goal of 50
incredible incredible somebody asking
will the FTC come break down your door
if you use the coupon code 20 20 now
they probably will not they probably
will not I would not I would not worry
too too much about that at this point in
time other super chats coming in um
let's see I don't want to miss any and
I've a lot of these have scrolled past
Casper from Denmark I'm learning so much
about my name very informative stream
David keep it up thank you Jimmy big
nuts favorite Trump nickname I like Joe
munchkin mansion you know I actually
tend to like mini just mini for Michael
Bloomberg I find absolutely hilarious
and I'm the same height as Michael
Bloomberg I'm sitting on five boxes
right now there's nothing wrong with
being 5/8 it's everything's fine I'm not
I'm not short shaming I actually got a
via an email from someone saying they
were furious with me that I was
participating in the short shaming it's
like I'm the same height as Michael
Bloomberg I'm not that's not what I'm
doing
ch burke floyd the fourth says video
deep dive on crypto slash election
positions maybe let me put that one at
maybe hilltop ayran works says NB c--
politics website has it oh that's yes we
saw that one good yeah good okay k whack
k Wozzeck three sends a super chat
abused plasma sends a super chat brooks
Madden what do you think about the
current divisive and chaotic nature of
our national politics and how do you
think it will impact America's future I
am genuinely very concerned about it and
I'm not doing any of this unity stuff
where it's like oh unity when it's this
person winning but not when it's that
person winning or what you know I am
concern
about the division in the country and
the hyper-partisanship
and I did a video about it a couple of
weeks ago which I invite you to check
out with peace and love of course Matt
Chavez says if Bernie wins it all
what's a realistic time frame Medicare
for all will be passed and implemented
I'm thinking 2022 after the midterms to
even pass I believe that if you if
Bernie Sanders is president and I
support Medicare for all
I support Medicare for all I support
Medicare for all I'm in favor of
Medicare for all I would support
Medicare for all if I were voting on it
in the Senate or in the house I'm in
favor of Medicare for all I need to do
this because otherwise people will go
crazy I don't think we see Medicare for
all in the first Bernie Sanders term I
just don't think we see it I would do
everything I can to make it a reality
I would lobby for it I would call Ed
Markey I would call everybody I just
don't think it's going to happen in a
first first bernie term many if not most
democratic senators are not even for
medicare for all and I know everybody
says Bernie will go in front of the
public and declare it an emergency and
he'll get it done in ba-ba-ba-ba-ba I
would love that and I will lobby for it
and I don't think it's going to happen I
think it will be a starting point and I
know a lot of people dislike me for it
dislike the stream do whatever you want
I tell you things as I see them that's
it
David are you against Medicare for all
very clever very very clever okay let me
say thank you to a couple of other
people or at least one Matthew Brennan
is new member number 22 today thanks
Matthew
I appreciate that and we are now just 28
subscribers away from our goal of 50 ok
Cahill 7 damn you David I have been
avoiding that clip the cringe is real it
makes me wonder what I need to do to get
a well paid job and suck at it let's
just look at it one more time because it
is so oh wait is this it no this is this
is Jamie Harrison but it's not okay it's
not the clip this is the clip right here
let's look at it one more time Chris
Matthews getting his black guys confused
Jamie I see you standing next to the guy
you're going to be
right there maybe maybe maybe Lindsey
Graham Scott Sims guy Jamie who's that
that's Tim Scott hey I'm saying oh it's
the other say Scott what am I saying
big mistake mistaken identity sir sorry
tell me how you gonna be done Lindsey
yeah there you go
that's pretty cringe so last week we
heard from last week we heard from Chris
Matthews that Burnie winning the Nevada
caucus was like the Nazis invading
France this week we heard from Chris
Matthews that and that's that's a sort
of sort of where we are today the Beck
manator says hey David love from Canada
do you think if Bernie does well on
Super Tuesday it'll increase the
likelihood that he gets a majority of
Delegates well yeah yeah well PS don't
worry about mispronouncing my name I get
it a lot Vegard Feldberg says what do
you think about brave browser I know
very little about it abused plasma says
have you ever been to Scotland
I have not KY Zuka 3 sends a super chat
G Brown has grabbed a youtube
subscription Dylan Tyler says I'm
surprised not more people are supporting
Bernie based solely off the consistency
of his values and message throughout the
years he's incredibly reliable dumb ass
loser what is your degree beyond
economics I think you may have a
master's right so my my bachelor's
degree is in oh my Fitbit just flew off
my wrist excuse me my bachelor's degree
is in economics and communication and
then I have a master's in business
specializing in economics and
entrepreneurship okay computer says Rep
our CP polls would give Bernie about 50%
of Delegates after s T due to non
viability of most candidates bernie is
the only one viable in all Super Tuesday
states
that's an interesting statistic rational
Enquirer when do we start talking about
protests if it looks like the nomination
will be stolen from Bernie people are
already talking about
that the dude hi David tuning in from NL
is that the Netherlands as I do every
primary just a bit of a flavor question
would you happen to have a favourite
Dutch American yeah my friend Evan
Albert's is my favorite Dutch American
Evan Sutherland says given that Biden
hasn't been in a Super Tuesday in over a
month what happens after his win doesn't
seem poised for super success sleepy Joe
we will see that is a perfectly
reasonable question let's see what else
we have happening so far and now we are
just about 40 minutes away from initial
results let's see what other primary
streams we have going now so we've got
CBS and ABC there's my stream which is
great local news we can't do that's
that's bad local news we want to stay
away from PBS newshour but they're not
covering the primary and none of these
other streams do I recognize so I think
I think we're in pretty good shape with
these two streams that we have going
right now
Brandon getter says CNN whoops CNN just
reported that 50% are Pro
medicare-for-all in South Carolina yes
we just saw those numbers Kay was get
three says love your YouTube stream
because I pause and catch up at 2x oh
that's an interesting interesting tactic
that is an interesting one let me say a
few other thank-yous I want to say a big
big thank you to Cynthia stone 'el who
is new member number 23 at join
pakman.com and I want to say thank you
to Deborah Simpson who is new member
number 24 at join pakman.com appreciate
your support come on in and grab a
membership at join pakman.com but don't
worry there's free ways to support these
streams and case in point
you know I've told you guys before that
when people like the stream on youtube
and subscribe to it we get preferential
treatment in YouTube's algorithm case in
point if you go to youtube right now and
you type in South Carolina's results
and you filter for live events the
second one that comes up is this stream
right here why is that it's because I
don't lie to you guys I tell them when
my YouTube rep tells me you want to get
people to like and subscribe off of your
stream because that will tell YouTube to
go in and recommend the stream to more
people I'm telling the truth
when that happens so make sure to LIKE
and subscribe if you are joining us now
on on YouTube it really does make a huge
difference ok other or now let me do
some some twitch membership membership
shoutouts and questions and all of that
stuff Maur week
20 has grabbed a you to a a twitch prime
sub and says dennis kucinich
is going to win with alien votes that's
a possibility oh sorry we didn't over on
the wrong thing here there we go
Zarek's has subscribed with twitch Prime
Joe Wyatt has subscribed with prime da
Wayne own has subscribed on twitch is
cold the Jones Y has subscribed with
Prime and SCANA Sciuto has subscribed as
well with twitch prime I appreciate that
oh can I do closed captions people
asking I believe I can let's see so we
can keep an eye on what's going on
they're gonna cover some things
potentially which is a little bit a
little bit not ideal let's see if we can
get it there we go alright not bad the
the buck manator you pronounce my name
correctly on the first try I'm so proud
of you thank you Zack Finley says shout
out to Beck since I see him at rat NAT -
Bob the dyno can you explain the with
peace and love thing you say so when
Ringo Starr the Beatle the Beatles
drummer announced oh I can move these
let's see oh I can move those ok let's
put them up here that's great great idea
I'm gonna move these so they don't block
key information when Ringo Starr
announced that he didn't want to sign
souvenirs for people anymore he was
basically saying kind of like screw off
like stop sending me crap but he kept
saying what
peace and love peace and love I am not
accepting any more stuff to be signed
after such a date so whenever I'm
community at communicating information
that's critical or negative in some way
I channel that by saying you know I say
this with total peace and love but
you've got to adjust your behavior in
this way or that way or expectations
Eamonn min-ji's says even though you're
5-8 your hands are more in proportion
with a man 6-2 or 6-3 you know that's
actually true I was able to palm a
full-size basketball in 6th grade 6th
grade it's it is true that I have
unusually large hands for my height a
very different than Donald Trump who is
he claims 6-3 I think more like 511 and
a half but has noticeably very small
hands I can't even really do small hands
I guess it kind of like this but ya know
I was able to palm a basketball and my
head is very very large and I can put my
hands completely around it let's see
here and you know what they say about
people with large large hands I have to
get large gloves I am a size small and
just about everything because I'm only a
5/8 guy as many of you know but gloves I
do have to get size large gloves it's
completely out of proportion and in fact
this is a story some of you may like a
Ukrainian friend of mine who has an
interesting sense of humor who used to
work with me at Circuit City when I was
in high school he noticed that not only
are my hands large but my arms are quite
long almost ape-like in a way he would
walk around kind of squatting down in
order for his hands to be almost down at
his ankles pretending that my arms just
normally when I put them down at my
sides go down well below my knees and he
would do this while I was trying to sell
extended service plans to customers and
it was extremely distracting and I'm
pretty sure that because he was my
manager his bonus depended on me selling
those those extended service plans but
he would still distract me in that way
that's what I've known for that's what
I'm known for rather I don't know what
to tell you Tyler solder says will trump
kovat response anger the prepper base
good question I don't know
Timothy s it's my 4 pound Chihuahuas 4th
birthday give her love love to the
Chihuahua vos says hello David from our
essays that the Republic of South Africa
is RSA South Africa recommended
dystopian sci-fi dystopian sci-fi well I
mean you know 1984 and brave new world
you've got to check out there's a book
called Lucifer's hammer which is very
dystopian very dystopian which is it is
very good if you're a little queasy
about ORS a technology conference in San
Francisco ok if you are queasy about
cannibalism I don't think I'm giving
anything away don't read Lucifer's
hammer other dystopian sci-fi there is
so much check out david pakman.com slash
recommendations because I have a I have
a bunch of recommendations there let's
listen in a little bit as I refill my
water - what's going on here Tuesday's
debate our major Garrett spoke to Joe
Biden about what a win in South Carolina
means to him let's listen to some of
that if you don't win South Carolina can
Joe Biden former vice president carried
on in this campaign with any hope the
nominee you're gonna win I'm gonna win
South by how much I don't know what does
it matter I think it's just important
that I win
just letting point is enough one point
is enough but I think I remember a lot
more than that
so how much is his campaign banking on
tonight's results I mean they they
really they feel really good his
campaign surrogates supporters are all
feeling really good about tonight but I
don't know that it's correct that just a
win is enough right now
Biden really needs to show some strength
people are talking about a double-digit
lead so I think the campaign in the last
24 hours has been trying to sort of
temper expectations but at the same time
he really does he needs to signal that
there's some momentum here and he's
frankly out of cash he's gotten a good
boost to cash in the last week but it's
come late and he needs the media
attention he needs a medium narrative
and he just needs the momentum coming
out of South Carolina and the only way
to do that is to win big here all right
Natasha kuraki for us in Columbia
Natasha thank you very much still to
come we asked South Carolina voters what
issues are on top of mind as they head
to the polls your streaming red and blue
live from Charleston South Carolina well
ladies gentlemen let me first say to all
of either we in the last few moments
have been trying to locate governor
Reagan and and Miami to congratulate him
on what I think is as a as a significant
victory here in South Carolina
I want to he's entitled to
congratulations and I certainly want to
extend them to him well Ronald Reagan
won in South Carolina I congratulate him
did a first-class job and now we set our
sights on Florida
if campaign had a long long I think very
productive day here and looking ahead
till Tuesday
you can watch CBS n 24/7 we've got an
amazing story to share with you let's
talk about the latest developments
there's so many levels to this we have a
CBS News exclusive fires in California
what happens next and how does it all
play out I understand you have some
breaking news it's not over yet as the
bottom line this is a massive operation
it's quite an adventure here at CBS s
it's been a day
we are just 27 minutes from polls
closing in South Carolina it is
conceivable that we will have some early
results right at the top of the hour I
don't know part of it is going to depend
also on how close it is and the
management of the results as many of you
know that is a very very big thing we
learned that in Iowa very quickly let me
say thank you to a new member named hold
on a second I actually a bunch of people
came in here okay
Dylan Powell is new member number 25
tonight Evan Sutherland is new member
number 26 tonight Kate gold Hirsch is
new member number 27
tonight actual context is new member
number 28 tonight and Denis McNamara is
new member number 29 tonight thank you
so much I really appreciate your support
and we are about 60% of the way to to
tonight's goal if you're just joining us
we are live on YouTube twitch and
Facebook we are taking questions from
you either via YouTube super chat those
show up in the bottom left of the screen
or via twitch prime or twitch sub
messages at the top right of the screen
a few videos that we reviewed today
already which I will refresh for you
here is Chris Matthews getting his black
politicians confused Jaime I see you
standing next to the guy you're gonna
beat right there maybe maybe maybe
Lindsey Graham she's got some stuff
Jaime
who's that Tim Scott hey I'm saying oh
it's the other say what am I saying
big mistake mistaken identity serves a
huge huge huge cringe then here is
Donald Trump in the middle of the
continued harebrained response to
coronavirus last night saying that no
one had yet died of course someone did
die today and mentioning that we have
ordered elements of medical elements of
medical this tremendous spirit a lot of
spirit and as you know with the flu
on average we lose from 26,000 to 78,000
people here even more than that and some
some cases some years we haven't lost
anybody yet and hopefully we can keep
that intact we there have been no deaths
in the United States at all a lot of
that's attributable to the fact that we
closed the border very early otherwise
it could be a different story
so well we'll just keep doing a good job
we're ordering a lot of supplies we're
ordering a lot of a lot of elements and
frankly we wouldn't be ordering unless
it was something like this but we're
ordering a lot of different elements of
medical we are working on cures and
we're getting some if it wasn't
absolutely dystopian ly horrible
elements of medical would just be funny
but it's actually completely toxic and
there is here is sleepy Trump sleepy
Trump barely coherent at a conference
this morning about coronavirus talking
about Isis it's been a long journey in
Afghanistan in particular it's been a
very long journey it's been a it's been
a hard journey for everybody we're very
largely a law enforcement group and
that's not what our soldiers are all
about right now their fighters are the
greatest fighters in the world as you
know we've destroyed in Syria and you
might say what does that have to do with
coronavirus and the answer is of course
nothing nothing whatsoever other super
chats green and purple without Medicare
for all uninsured people will suffer
horribly from Co vat19
yes that is absolutely correct the stone
cold bottom oh sorry hold on when a
bunch of super chats come in at once
things just scroll up the stone cold
bottom who do you think is Sanders most
viable beep VP choice again I'm not
doing VP stuff for now I don't I don't
see the advantage
Joseph said Agassi you pronounce my name
perfectly it's literally the reason I
keep throwing money at you you pronounce
exit strangely though exit exit that's
interesting I do pronounce it exit as
opposed to exit Wow I'd never knew that
somebody pointed out that I pronounced
new with a liquid you as opposed to new
like I have a new car versus I have a
new car I've always said new waffles
derp Awful's if president will Bernie
need to adopt Trump's direct messaging
tactics addressing the public to
pressure the party in line with his
policies I don't know I don't see why he
would he doesn't have to do everything
the way Trump does it downfall parodies
says Jesse Lee Peterson vs. vermin's
supreme for POTUS definitely vermin
definitely vermin Dylan Tyler is it
possible Mayer McCheese comes away with
a few delegates tonight uh yeah it seems
it's anybody's game tonight thanks to a
Don Stewart for signing up on YouTube
dusty Dark Horse says from being not
sure we could hit 10 new members in a
live stream to being in our 20s before
results even start coming in killing it
David killing it David thank you so much
and we are actually going to get even
closer
I dare say a Don Stewart is new member
number 30 at join PAC low no not three
thirty thirty at join pakman.com I also
want to say thanks to Lauri Beverly who
is new member number 31 at join
pakman.com thank you I appreciate that
comrade Matthias is your partner
satisfied with your hand size very much
so very much so and really you know one
of the things about palming a basketball
it's not just about the length of the
fingers it's about being a
able to really be you know get around
the ball so to speak that's a big part
of it and I if you ask me what is most
attributable what can I most attribute
to being able to palm a basketball in
sixth grade it's not the size of my hand
so much is really getting that spread
you want to get as close to a full
circle as possible and more than a
hundred and eighty degrees as you go
around here particularly if I really
really stretch there and I could
recommend some exercises for that as
well um let's see Collins CNE do you
ever play video games in your free time
you know I used to play more video games
than I do now I never played a lot but
now that I've reaffirmed my love of
chess in my adulthood the time I would
normally I used to spend playing video
games which was not much i I I play
chess for the most part Bell says hey
mr. Pakman first time early voter from
North Carolina I'm feeling the burn
Joseph's disease hummus Serta Heaney
Halle or Lacock rugelach or sufyani oats
shawarma or falafel that's a lot of
questions let me just put it this way
kala above almost all else and falafel
over almost all else but really
chocolate babka above everything else
above everything else that's for sure
Rob not Bob what is one opinion you used
to hold that you now disagree with uh
what's a good question I mean just
generally I might I was indoctrinated
into standard economics in high school
and until I was disabused of a lot of
those notions I believed a lot of that
stuff that doesn't really work anymore
also planning on streaming any strategy
games on Twitch no I don't think I am
RSA equals South Africa yes thanks for
the recommendations oh so turkey bacon
and cheese was wrong RSA is South Africa
people asking what is kala kalah is a
brett-brett
braided egg bread traditionally eaten on
Shabbat Friday nights
and leftovers used on Saturday morning
to make challah french toast and Mike
challah french toast is tremendous you
should see what goes on in my kitchen
when I start making the French toast
it's I almost have to call the police
because there's people it's like it's
like a zombie show where people are
crawling up my windows and trying to
bash it them in and break into my house
when challah french toast is made it is
it's absolutely a fantastic bread which
I highly highly recommend to you let me
say thank you to a couple of other
people Michael Sakana is new member
number 32 tonight and oh that's it okay
just Michael add join pakman.com if
you're just joining us we are 19 minutes
maybe from the first results in South
Carolina
we're moderate monitoring CBS News
coverage we are monitoring ABC news
coverage we are trying to avoid a
technical Fiasco because there are a lot
of strange things happening today with
my streaming setup but hopefully it will
all hold up if you're just joining us on
YouTube please remember to hit the
subscribe and like buttons because of
your support and hitting like and
subscribe right now if people search for
South Carolina results live streams we
are the second one that comes up our
little old tiny YouTube channel is
coming up in front of CBS News thanks to
you fine folks hitting like and
subscribe which is amazing it's truly
truly amazing and I very much appreciate
that let's continue seeing what's on
folks Minds Ivan Monroy has signed up on
YouTube ey TPS says debate John Burke I
have no clue who that is X says have you
read books by Chuck tingle his titles
and covers are great I have never read a
Chuck tingle book Eamon min-ji's says by
the way my name is pronounced Ayman
phonetically oh I'm sorry
Ayman min-ji's thank you I appreciate
that
I like oh I'll likely
be headed to the base at Shackleton
crater in November of 2050 it's a
three-day flight but if I can get you
another ticket do you want to come with
me well in 2058 I would be I'll be old I
don't know if I'll be in any kind of
condition to be going to a crater
Nicolai Gaiety has grabbed a youtube
subscription and true says what website
do you pull results from oh you know
something we'll use different websites
each stream but tonight I mean in 17
minutes
we may see some results here on CBS or
ABC momentarily
let's see just Restrepo J Restrepo o 8
what are some straight strategies Burnie
can use to get his policies adopted once
he is president it's going to come down
to negotiating big Li with Democrats in
the Senate
Burnie is going to need Democrats in the
Senate to come over to his side on a lot
of policies and that is going to take
it's going to take some negotiation for
sure she so lion dog says Burnie loss in
South Carolina is just a speed bump we
will have an insurmountable lead after
Super Tuesday should dominate most
primaries thereafter love your show
K WASC 3 says how important is VP really
after election Kyle how important is VP
really after election Kyle I apologize
but I don't understand the question
Zach Finley how many producer level
supporters do you have I don't know I'd
have to look into that
Evans Sutherland says is Pete in
desparate used Carl's car salesman mode
he's not there yet
but he may be getting close depending on
the results on Super Tuesday Ben Taylor
I saw your dog is ready to dreidel it's
d-r-e i de l yeah i posted a picture to
my instagram page i don't know if people
want to check this out it's not my dog
it's actually my dad's dog and i
frequently put things on his head and
he's a very very good boy so he allowed
me to put a big wooden dreidel on his
head and I posted that recently with the
message he's ready early for Passover
although someone pointed out dreidel is
really more of a
Konica thing than it is Passover but in
any case he's still a UH he's a handsome
handsome dog that yeah it's hard to see
but anyway you can find it on my
Instagram at David Pakman very important
discussions here until we get these
results at the top of the hour
ey TPS says is penny wise scary to you
penny wise the band not that I'm aware
of now Nikolai Getty says sorry for my
weird Danish last name good day no need
to apologize
no need to apologize ever for for your
name let me say thank you and welcome to
you Gerard Fernando who is new member
number 33 of the evening officially
getting us two-thirds of the way to our
goal of 50 we may just be 13 and a half
minutes away from the first results out
of South Carolina we don't know we'll
see every state handles the primary
differently we'll see how much is
counted at the top of the hour but we
are just about 13 minutes away oh uh
they're the broke on it Rokon is a
friend of the show I will sometimes
Twitter DM Withrow he is being
interviewed we will maybe get some
results at the top of the hour we may
not every every primary is run a little
bit differently let me say thank you
over on twitch to Skrill as 247 for the
twitch prime sub and let me say thank
you to Kay book 3 for the twitch Prime
subscription over on Twitch very much
appreciated
ey TPS says I'm talking about the clown
penny wise I have no clue what you're
talking about
Lenna --the any concerns with bogus
copyright issues tonight of course Ben
Taylor no penny wise in the drain prob
very handsome pup geez I don't know what
people are is this me being a boomer I
don't know what people are talking to me
about I really have no idea anything
could be going on I just have no clue
thanks to Paul Phan tests with a $2.00
Canadian super chat and the message cool
I see people in the chat checking in
from very very far away all sorts of
different countries yeah let me know in
the chat where people are watching from
I'm curious if I know our friend pair
from Sweden is watching and it's getting
pretty late there what countries are
folks watching from today anybody
anybody Canada New Zealand Australia
Finland Austria and Australia a lot of
Finland that's interesting Sweden
Belgium love Belgium Mexico Argentina no
way that's interesting
Denmark UK Norway I think we might have
like 30 or 40 different countries
represented that's very interesting
Poland the Republic of tulsi that's
interesting Austria Germany I'm seeing
what's new China oh that's interesting
Greece Spain a lot of different places
very very interesting a lot of people in
China China a lot of EU people yeah yeah
it's starting to get late in Canada
that's interesting Russia Uganda South
Africa the great country of Indiana
China somebody says yeah that's it
that's an interesting place I've been
there um let's see here John Cusack says
penny wise from Stephen King's it I I
have now I've only read one Stephen King
book The Outsider that's my full
familiarity with Stephen King's work
Dillinger sciatic says people debate
compulsory voting why not a modest voter
tax credit why not end war but refocus
spending on research historical benefit
for example ARPANET cos take on fountain
pens in the university I use them for
notes yeah I uh when I was at the
University I attended actually this is I
buy a bunch of these I use a uni-ball
signo I guess it's a 207 and I use black
ink I don't know if that makes me racist
against blue but I that this is my
preferred pen and I've been with this
pen for a while
it works for me and I've got just boxes
and boxes of them and that this is what
I used I wouldn't really be able to say
too too much else okay we are just
minutes away from polls closing in South
Carolina nine and a half minutes away we
are seeing an interview that was done
earlier today with our friend ro Khanna
a Bernie Sanders supporter endorser and
surrogate I guess we would say we are
expecting Joe Biden to win the question
is by how much if Joe Biden doesn't win
tonight given the polling and as you can
see here the degree to which Joe Biden
surged in the polls here this green line
is big if Joe Biden just doesn't win
tonight Joe Biden is all but done so we
are waiting to see what will happen
there if Joe Biden wins the question of
by how much becomes relevant to can he
build momentum going into Super Tuesday
mathematically the most likely to
outcomes after Super Tuesday are no one
is likely to get to 50% plus one
delegates or Bernie is likely to get to
50% plus one delegates unless we see a
total reversal it is unlikely that any
scenario will will sort of surface after
Super Tuesday let's see other messages
coming in Nick Holcomb says I put $5.00
on Chlo Bashar dropping out next what
are your thoughts
I think steyr or Tulsi drop out next
somebody says that my audio is out of
sync with my video that would be
shocking that would be shocking we have
never had that issue before can anybody
else tell me whether my audio and video
are out of sync if we're having that
issue it's it's a problem okay
everybody says it's fine it's a
millisecond behind it's fine hmm a
couple people saying maybe it is the
tiniest bit oh that's interesting
that is very interesting we've never
experienced that 99% of people are
saying that it's actually fine though so
that's that that's pretty interesting we
are minutes from polls closing in South
Carolina
let me say welcome and hello to Zach
attack who says via super chat love the
show and also love that you knew penny
wise as the band not the character Kelly
Dee shout out from Martinique Thank You
Heather won't ikot with a super chat
waffles Durrell's downer trump makes me
google adel Rodriguez's art and Shaz kay
has subscribed via YouTube as well let
me say thank you and welcome to Kyle in
dibs who is new member number 34 of the
evening do you guys think we can knock
out the 50 new member target by the top
of the hour before we get the South
Carolina primary results starting to
come in we are 16 new members away let
me do some math it only takes 45 seconds
to get a membership because I don't
carry the zero we're on like a 20-second
delay I think we could I actually think
we could get to 50 new members by the
top of the hour at join pakman.com and I
don't even care if people use the
discount 2020 now take the two-thirds
discount it's not means-tested it's
available for everybody most people
think we can't do it I love it when
people are optimistic Stan sprinkle says
David thanks for all the work you do
Romeo Alpha has grabbed a youtube
membership K was three says with a
strong president how much value is a
vice president really own oh yeah that's
a good point
you need your vice president to just not
tank things for you they need to
basically stay out of the way and not
dissuade voters a strategic pick to run
Senate is no more bring that back
elevate non senator Kay Ellison thanks
Kyle hmm Roger Larson says thanks for
holding me saying in these trying times
keep it up David John Cusack says do you
exercise what do you do yes I go to the
gym I will alternate cardio between the
treadmill and the elliptical and then I
just walk around and pick up weights and
then put them down Nathan a low back has
also grabbed a youtube youtube
subscription I see people are getting
ramped up now as we are just minutes
from potentially the first results out
of South Carolina we are
six minutes from maybe getting some
results because polls do close very very
soon in South Carolina and it is
anyone's guess when we will know the
results tonight Adam Christopher Meade
says would you be willing to support my
music I don't know anything about it so
I I would need to know something about
it Paul sir-sir nosov do you like Anna's
taqueria in Boston uh it's not bad yeah
yeah it's not a bad spot not a bad spot
for a quick bite Caspar from Denmark why
did Biden surge so much what amazing
thing that he do to deserve that well he
focused in South Carolina spent a lot of
time there put money into there and he
got an icky endorsement from congressman
Clybourn did he save an orphan from a
burning burning building not quite not
quite cos love your data pensions
physics stats major and I get frequent
looks of consternation when I bring
stats up yeah a lot of people get
visibly angry when you present them with
data visibly visibly angry let me say
thank you to even man 27 for subscribing
with twitch Prime and Trevor Dell Kerr
for subscribing on twitch as well as
Java Fox 98 super dodgeball optimist one
three three seven one and Max punches
for subscribing on Twitch as well and
osoi Biba oh is SOI OVAs SOI but not
sure how that's a lot of consonants
there that is a hell of a lot of
consonants let me say thank you and
welcome to Travis Venice Travis is new
member number 35 tonight Quan gana we is
new member number 36 tonight or is it
gonna we not sure but it's definitely
one also want to say thanks to Kevin
Booker who is new member number 37
tonight as we are just three minutes
from polls closing in South Carolina
clever to swear says can you please do a
drum cover of
Old Town Road let me let me think about
that I'm going to put that under under
advisement and see what we can come up
with there if you are joining us on
YouTube with a total humility I ask you
to hit the like and subscribe button
because you have done that the stream
has been pretty steady with around 5,000
people watching make sure to hit like
and subscribe it's free it costs you
nothing and if you are refusing to hit
like and subscribe on YouTube tell me
why in the chat I want to know why
people are going to refuse to do like
and subscribe because to me it seems
that it's a it's a no brainer I would
just do it so let me know in the chat
why you would would not be willing to do
that as we are just minutes now
potentially from the first results
because I don't like you David okay
that's actually fair that's a fair
that's a fair reason not to do it
someone says David only reads super
chats people he's not acknowledging your
comments let alone responding to them
well that that was not a super chat miss
Nene I saw that that's for sure
fascinating people saying they don't
want to subscribe because they don't
want to get too many videos in their
feed easy solution you subscribe and
then turn off notifications for this
channel very very easy logic 101 so no
hold on Michael Green feels long as you
did I miss parents here and what kind of
voting system do they use in South
Carolina paper or digital I don't know
the answer to that very good question
experience music if you had to bet on
three people to be Bernie's be pick VP
pick who would you who would you pick as
I said a bunch of times I'm not doing VP
stuff yet I think it's a distraction and
possibly divisive Jose Rodriguez is a
new member
logic 101 if bernie names face the
Abrams tomorrow he won't lose another
state I don't know about that another
user whose user name is a face drawn
with punctuation do the results of South
Carolina even matter I get it's a good
indication for who's going to pull ahead
but is in everything but and everything
basically decided on Super Tuesday the
results tonight
influence results on Super Tuesday so in
that sense it does it does matter let's
see we are very close very close to
maybe getting some results john cusack
how do you enjoy your coffee if you
drink it I basically am I'm 99% on
espresso based strengths I'm basically
off what I would call drip or filter
coffee and cappuccino is my preferred
drink in the morning Cortado or an
espresso in the afternoon that's that's
where I'm at
Christian Kozma hello from Romania keep
it up David thank you and welcome I
appreciate that very very much
appreciate that let's say thank you to a
couple of other people who have grabbed
some memberships let's see if I can do
the correct pronunciations here Lenna
--the Albanese is new member number 38
luis Aponte is new member number 39
chase Corvo is new member number 40
Nabil Kaveri is new member number 41 and
Daniel Rabkin is new member number 42
very close 42 out of 50 new members
there as we are now awaiting live
results let's see what we got from the
Carolina Ale House in Charleston we
begin with an update on today's race CBS
News projects Joe Biden will win the
South Carroll Dover Democratic primary
leaders based on exit polls but until
then I want to welcome our panel Caitlyn
Huey Byrnes Leslie Sanchez and Linda
Tran so the pretend political reporter
Leslie is a CBS News political analyst
and Republican strategist Linda is a
cbs2 let's see if ABC is also calling it
I'm guessing this is an ABC News
election update
now reporting George Stephanopoulos good
evening we are coming on the air now
with breaking news in the race for the
White House
ABC News projects that Joe Biden will
win today's Democratic primary in the
state of South Carolina
it's his first win of the 20/20 campaign
after lagging behind in Iowa so what
this tells us is that the win is so
overwhelming based on the exit polls
that even if the exit polls were
statistically more often they've ever
been we would still see Joe Biden win so
there it is ladies and gentlemen Joe
Biden winning it is going to be a fight
now for the delegates going in it looked
like Joe Biden was was roughly polling
around 39% he may even end up with more
he may end up with less we don't know
but it is a win for Joe Biden if you are
joining us we have the results we have
the numbers Joe Biden's first win and
that that that appears to be so
overwhelming a win that they are ready
to call it now an incredible turn of
events not really it was exactly what we
were expecting and a whole bunch of
people seemingly fired up by it and they
are grabbing memberships Eddie
Estevez a pinot is new member number 43
Eric Yeager is new member number 44
thanks to both of you and the big news
Joe Biden Joe Biden the winner tonight
called basically everywhere already the
only question is delegates
is it only Bernie and Joe who get
delegates and by what margin does Joe
Biden win clever to swear asks David can
I have your hairline I would gladly give
it to you if I could
Jorge Martinez what states can Joe Biden
do well in just curious we're gonna look
at that on Monday Charles Barse is a new
YouTube member Nick Holcomb how did your
Joe Rogan appearance affect your channel
got about 8,000 new subscribers dusty
Dark Horse vermin's supreme for
vice-president Mack swanky has signed up
on YouTube shale is preferential voting
used in any primaries if you mean ran
choice Maine has ranked choice and there
might be one or two other states
experience music why is there anything
rather than nothing as a fellow drummer
do you enjoy tool I'm not a big tool fan
and I don't know why there is anything
rather than nothing one of the mysteries
of our time comic Kate has grabbed a
youtube subscription Angeline Siebel or
Seibel I'm in South Carolina machine
voting with paper backup mic Lightner
CBS calls it for Biden Sam Kenyon any
tips on how to have a productive or
civil conversation with
ultra-conservatives that seemed to live
in their own reality yes don't talk
about politics mike Lightner Biden wins
his first star in almost 40 years Luke
why are you parroting lamestream news
the results aren't in at all love your
show got it the exit polls are clearly
so overwhelming that Joe Biden won it's
they're not all gonna get this wrong
Ricky Williams greatest of all time MTV
Unplugged in Nirvana or Alice in Chains
Nirvana I'm not an Alice in Chains guy
and I apologize to everybody who's
furious with me because of that but I
just have never been Suzy Harrison is
new member number 45 today and I very
much appreciate that Joe Biden has won
the South Carolina primary on that note
as I mentioned I do have plans starting
in a half hour so that does it for me
tonight full coverage on Monday and
plenty of other streams to watch until
midnight but the results we know Joe
Biden winning in south care